[Alkış]
Biz Selam veririz
çıkışta ama
Merhaba herkese çok enteresan gerçekten
çok enteresan şu anda yaşadığım Duygu
çok enteresan Ben bu sahneye Sadece oyun
oynamak için çıkarım en son izleyeniniz
vardır belki annemin son çılgınlıkları
İzmir devlet tiyatrosunda onunla gelip
oynamıştım burada o oyunla ama konuşmacı
olarak bu benim yaşamımda ilk ha
konuşmacı olduğum söyleşiler yaptık
falan ama böyle birebir bu şekilde
çıkmam ilk defa onun için çok
farklı çok değişik bir duygu benim için
hoş geldiniz
Ben devlet tiyatrosuna girdikten sonra
bir hayal kurdum ve o hayalimi de
gerçekleştirdim çok şükür Ha devam ettim
E edemedi o hayalim şeydi benim
Aydınlıyım Ben doğma büyüme hem anne hem
baba tarafından
Hatta hakiki Efe torunlarıyız ben
Aydın Devlet Tiyatrosu yazsın istemiştim
bunu çok istedim çok arzu ettim
çok uğraştık kardeşimin eşi yapımda Ben
bizzat genel müdürlükle ve kendi
müdürümle habire paslaşarak
Şükran Güngör sahnesi Aydın
hatırlayanınız vardır gençler çocuklar
bilmezler Aralarda
Yani benim yaşımda Öyle mi Öyle mi güzel
Aydın Devlet Tiyatrosu Şükran Güngör
sahnesi Çünkü Şükran abi de biliyorsunuz
çineli Aydın'ın çinesi Bence de çok
büyük alkış kendisine Nur içinde yatsın
bizim işimiz Usta Çırak ilişkisidir her
ne kadar bu işin eğitimini alsak da
sahnede olgunlaşır oyuncu o yüzden öyle
Ustalar her zaman başımızın tacıdır
şimdi o onu yazmak için çok uğraştık biz
oraya kilometre olarak yakın mesafeler
Aydın Kuşadası işte Aydın atıyorum İzmir
arasındaki mesafeler
kilometre olarak yakın olduğu için
yerleşik tiyatro olamaz prosedürü de
böyle bir şey yok ama tuvalet Tiyatrosu
olabilirdi yaptık dönemin şey kültür
bakanı Atilla
Acar genel müdürümüzdü
Şükran güngörü bilirsiniz Ben böyle
karşı tarafta merdivenlerde dışarıdayım
daha işte bir şekilde yani
Ya ne bileyim şuraya çıkıp da Allah'ım
Çok yani Of of filan böyle falan
yapabilmek için bekliyorum
şimdi
Neyse o taraflarını söylemeyeyim çok hoş
bir şey değil Atilla
Koçyiğit Koç kendisi
açılışı yaptı ya hani her şeyde kopardı
gibi yaptı ben münacar bana baktı Ben
böyle münacara baktım hani var mıyız
yoksa fark etmez ama Devlet Tiyatrosu
yazılımı yazıldı ha sonra gidebildiğimi
gitmedi Olmadı Sonra
yine hatırlayanlar bilenler bilirler
dönemin Nevzat Biçer
Ben burada ilk defa Nevzat Biçer ve şu
anda adını verdiğimiz sahnemizin Hidayet
Sayın benim çok kıymetli Türkiye için
çok kıymetli bir yazar çok kıymetli bir
Tıp Doktoru Harikulade bir insan çok
dolu dolu bir insan ve benim canım amcam
her şeyim bebek yani çocuk doktoru
olduğu için bebekliğimin 15 günden
itibaren beni tanıyan bir insan o yüzden
iyi ki böyle bir vefa yaptı Helal olsun
aydınımızın yaptığı en güzel şeylerden
bir tanesi bu Vefa örneğidir Hidayet
Sayın adını buraya bu sahneye vermektir
çok güzel biz
kendisiyle onun desteğiyle Ufuk Soğancı
vardı o zaman başkan yardımcılığı
yapıyordu
Aydın şehir tiyatrosunu kurduk O zaman
hep beraber ve orada halkımızdan çok
öğrenci de vardı
şimdi biliniyor mu Yani yine merdivenin
başında Gibi miyiz öyle ama olsun biz
bunları yaptık benim hayalim gerçekleşti
çok şükür
ben biraz şeyden bahsetmek istiyorum
sanat
çok uzun
çok
meşakkatli
olmazsa olmazımız
toplumlar Atatürk de söylemiş
biliyorsunuz Herkes her şey olabilir her
meslekten ama sanatçı olmak çok zordur
diye ve bir misyonumuz olduğuna
inanıyorum o yüzden
Ya şu doğru konuşmayı güzel konuşmayı
biraz konuşsak diyorum Son zamanda
Özellikle de sosyal medyada böyle haşır
neşir olma durumlarımız çok fazlalaşınca
şey yapmaya başladık
okuyorum ve hicap duyuyorum çok
üzülüyorum Ne olur siz gençsiniz Siz
bizim her şeyimizsiniz Biz yok olunca
Sizler var edeceksiniz Onun için ileri
gideceğiz her zaman Atatürk'ün yolundan
hiç ayrılmadan Biz bunu niçin yapacağız
İlk önce Türkiye'miz Dünyamız kendi Ama
bakın doğru Türkçeyi konuşabilmek bizim
vatanımız için çok önemli Herkes kendi
diline nasıl sahip oluyorsa Biz de öyle
alalım çok güzel bir örnek var sağ ol
sal diye yazılır Evet Türkçede ğ okunmaz
zift dog yapar düşer ama niçin Sağ ol
diye yazıyorsunuz böyle bir Türkçe var
mı ya bizim yazın Başkadır konuşma başka
da hadi diyalektikler diyerek derseniz o
başka bir şey mesela
Aydın şimdi bütün şöyle söyleyeyim
Türkiye'de bölgelerin şiveleri vardır
İşte Ege Bölgesi şivesi Karadeniz şivesi
doğu şivesi ama ağızlar memleketlerdir
yani Aydın ağzı Denizli ağzı Burdur ağzı
şöyle bir örnek vereyim Ben size
Aydın gari derken Burdur gayın der Ama o
da gayrı demektir aslında ama o gayin
der biz Muğla'ya Muğla deriz ama
muğlalılar kendilerine Moğollar
şimdi bakın
diyalek yapmak Türkçeyi bozmak demek
değildir diyalek Başka bir şey ama
Türkçemizi bozmasak da doğru Türkçe
konuşsak olur mu Ben sizden şeyi
istemiyorum şu kadar önemlisini bu kadar
olmasın da varsın Hani önemli değil
bakın
keşke keşke diyor Ah keşke diye bir
lafımız vardır keşke bunu kaç kişi
parmak kaldırsın ben görebilir miyim
bilmiyorum ama görmeye çalışırım bunun
Aslında okunuşunun keşke olduğunu bilen
kimdir var mıdır Ben söyleyinceye kadar
biliyor muydunuz
Keşke değildir keşkedir konuşurken Keşke
ben bunu yapmasaydımdır doğru Türkçe
budur Ama ben ondan Vazgeçtim Hani değil
diye yazarız değil diye okuruz O yumuşak
ki orada iki tane iyi oluşturur ama ben
onlardan vazgeçtim bu çok doğru bu
olması gerekiyor Bu olmazsa olmazımız
bakın yani yumuşak yerleri söylememek ol
ama yazmakta yazmak zorundasınız olmaz
Türkçeyi bozmayan yani işte yani Okey
diyoruz ok yazıyoruz ya bunu hep
yapıyoruz yani zamandan bunlar yanlış
aslında biliyor musunuz Yanlış
yapmamamız gereken şeyler Peki bir örnek
daha söyleyeceğim ben size
[Müzik]
beni oradan izleyebilecek misiniz
harfleri söyleyebilir misiniz şu harf
okur musunuz bütün olarak yazıyorum
Bana kim Bu yazdığımı ben söylemeyeceğim
kopya olmasın diye Kim Bu yazdığımı
Doğru Türkçe olarak söyleyebilir
Kim anlamadım
bir kişi kalkıp söyleyebilir mi Yani kim
Kim istiyorsa doğrusu nedir diye evet
dinliyorum göremiyorum sizi Işık
yüzünden
Hayır o yazılışı
Evet N harfi yok n dikdört yapar düşer
konuşulmaz sonradır E ben sonra giderim
sonra yaparım sonra gelirimdir
konuşurken Ama ben bu kadarını demiyorum
size Varsın olsun Bunu biz bilelim yani
bunu sanatçı oyuncu bir şey bilsin yani
Türkçeyi doğru konuşan hep beraber
konuşalım isterseniz ben susayım
rahatsız şeye rahatsızlık veriyorsam siz
şey yapın
bir şey anlatıyorum Çünkü
Yani şunu söylüyorum
ben sonra demenizden vazgeçtim Sonra
değil ama o o o veyahut da ne bileyim
yani çok örnekleri var sizde
söyleyebilirsiniz bu Türkçemizi güzel
kullanırsak her şeyimiz çok daha kolay
Çok daha güzel olacak Biz doğruları
öğretmiş olacağız çocuklarımıza siz de
büyüyeceksiniz anne baba olacaksınız
sizin de çocuklarınız olacak E nasıl
olacak yani işte bu yani hala değil mi
desinler ya değil demek varken hala
değil mi desinler olmaz değil mi Sonra
ben bakın doğru söylüyorum Sonra diye
Onu şey yapabilirsiniz alabilirsiniz bu
çok doğru bir şey Keşke kullansanız
kullanabilseniz yapılabilse Bunlar çok
güzel şeyler ama
maalesef
dilimizi şu sosyal medyadan başlayarak
şöyle birazcık değiştirmeye En azından
söz verir misiniz
gençler
Harikasınız Ben alkışlıyorum size
[Alkış]
Keşke bu parçalıklı bir soru ve cevap
şeklinde olan bir söyleşi olsaydı
anlatılacak konuşulacak yapılacak o
kadar bakın aklıma bir şey geldi
yapılacak konuşulacak anlatılacak bir
şey var derken bu arada da
sahneye şey olan birisi olarak ışıktan
da kaçmak istemiyorum bakın şuraya
gelirsem Işık olmayacak Yüzümde Öyle
değil mi Ama burada ışık var işte artık
bunlarda şimdi biraz evvel bir arkadaş
dedi ki ben çok heyecanlıyım ne yapıyor
böyle çok korkuyorum böyle elim ayağım
buz kesiyor Nefise bir şeydir bu
sahnenin heyecanı ne hoştur ama biz
oyuncular için bunu avantaja
çevirebilmek çok anlamlıdır gelirken sen
ki ben Kuşadası'ndan Geliyorum şimdi de
önüme bir şey çıktı benim çok uzun
zamandır Biz şu kamyon arkası yazılara
hiç rastlamaz olduk Ben en azından
rastlamaz olmuştum Çok uzun zamandır
ama önde giden 09 plakalı eskimiş
modelde
nefis bir yazı vardı Bakın size bir şey
söyleyeceğim hem Türkçemiz için hem de
diğerlerimiz için ne yazıyordu biliyor
musunuz
dertlerime zincir yaptım
Yani aslında bakın Aydın ağzıyla bu
şimdi ben normalde
dertlerime zincir yaptım dediğim zaman
işte bir tek hanımefendi fark edip
gülebildi ama dertlen zincir yaptım
derse herkes gülebilir
diyerek yapmak çok güzeldir Aydın ağzı
inanılmaz sempatik inanılmaz güzel bir
ağızdır çok eğlendirir çok güldürür ve
çok
Harikulade bir azdır ama ben oyunculara
da söylüyorum Keşke yani bilmeden
yapmasalar tam bu yöreye hakim olmadan
ağıza hakim olmadan yelek yapmak hiç hoş
değil işte eleştirmek gibi olmasın da
iki tane Zülüf böyle bir şeyin
arkasından yemenin Arkasından iki tane
böyle bırakan ve gari diyen herkesin
egazi konuşulduğuna inanılan dizileri
seyrettik şimdiye kadar yalan değil yani
eleştirmekse de eleştirmek
aranızda Fransızca bilen var mı Çok
güzel bir örnek geldi aklıma evet diyen
arkadaş bunun ne demek olduğunu söylesin
Ben zaten söyleyeceğim Bakın ben
diyalektin doğru olanın nasıl olduğunu
şey yapmak için bir örnekle bakın
dinleyin
jeepar Fransa ön pö ne dedim
oradan bir arkadaş var demişti Ben
biraz Fransızca konuşuyorum demek
hiçbirinizi etkilendiniz mi Japon Bak
tekrar et Japan Fransa önpü
etkileneniniz var mı Ama
dediğim zaman ah ah
bakın çok güzel güllüğün için söylüyorum
size de çok güzel hemen bunu Ege ağzına
getirelim
cumaların
çünkü hiçbir zaman tekil kullanmaz Ege
mutlaka Cuma 100 tane Cuma varmış gibi
cumalar der Cumaların mübarek olsun çok
kullanılan Ege'de bir isim Fadime Teyze
Cumaların mübarek olsun Fadime Teyze ay
etkilendiniz mi çok size böyle ağız
verdi mi böyle bir heves verdi mi bir
şey verdi mi Yok değil mi Cumaların
mübarek olsun Fadime nasılsın bakayım
İşte bu enternasyondur biz buna
entelasyonla bu şiirle diyalekti yaparız
Fransızcayı da derken ya da Rapunzel
dediğimiz zaman biz bunu melodisi ile
yaparız eğer o melodiyi
kullanmıyorlarsa bu diyalek yapılmasın
diyerek yapılmasın o zaman şimdi
Söylemesi ayıp beni
doğuda çekilecek bir sinema filmi için
menajerim aradı
ben başrolünü
hep unutuyorum Şeyin adını çok da
sevdiğim bir insandır onunla birlikte
başrolünü oynayacağız
sinema filmi yani İki buçuk üç haftada
bitecek olan bir şey ama ben
Urfalı
fadime'yim yani
konuşamam ki yani birinin tekrar etmesi
lazım bana benim hakimiyetim Ege ben
Karadeniz'de şeyle koy ha oyuncu olarak
konuşur muyuz yapacağımız bir iş var
Oyun oynayacağım bir şey yapacağım diğer
ekle bir şey var ya da işte sahnede
birini taklit edeceğim ya da
dizilerimden birinde ben mesela Fransız
kadın oynamıştım hanımın çiftliğinde
biliyorsunuz Madame Maya ama yani böyle
bir şey tekrar edeceğim mesela o zaman o
kadar hasbel kadar olabilir ama
başrolünü oynamaya Ben cesaret
edemiyorum Kusura bakmayın ben hayır
dedim
oraya hakim olmadıktan sonra yapmak
işgüzarlıktır bana göre Onun için
Türkçeyi güzel kullanmamakta Tıpkı
kamyonun arkasında şimdi Ege o kadar
sempatik dediğim o nasıl konuşuyorsa Bu
arada 18 dakika merhumumuz var
son
Tamam son iki dakika çok şeyler
konuşulur Aslında o kadar güzel şeyler
var anlatmak istediğim o kadar çok şey
var Yaşama Dair Şimdi ben kalkıp Size
buradan shakespeare'den ya da çaydan
size bahsedebilirim saatlerce de
sürebilir bu yani şeyden
diyalektik felsefeden başlayıp şeye
kadar bizim
lambada titriyor Alev denilen şarkı bir
diyalektik felsefeyi anlatır buradan
çıkarak sanata bağlayıp gidebilirim ama
hepiniz şişersiniz Ama ben doğru şeylere
yani güncel olanlara anlatmaya onları
aktarmaya çalışıyorum size o yüzden
şimdi ne oldu bakın arkada dertlerime
zincir yaptımın hiçbir anlamı olmadığı
dertler zinciri yaptım gari demenin
nasıl güzel olduğunu fark ettiniz işte
Türkçede de doğru Türkçede de son iki
dakikaya gir Son Bir dakikaya girdik
doğru Türkçede de eğer
dertlerime zincir yaptım gibi
konuşursanız kelimenin E harfini
benimseyip i harfini unutursanız bu hem
konuşmanızda hem yazmanızda Türkçemize
ve en önemlisi
atamıza büyük saygısızlık değil mi
son 36 şeye yani çingenelik yapmayalım
Hani son 36 saniye ile kullanacağız diye
bir şey yok ama işte ben sizinle inanın
tekrar buluşmak istiyorum gençler bizim
önümüze açacak aydınlatacak
kaç tane büyük kalkıp da
çocuklara gençlere Bayram yapmış ki onun
için bizim için bu kadar önemliyken
tekrar buluşalım Tekrar anlatalım tekrar
sohbet edelim ama bunlar karşılıklı
söyleşi şeklinde soru cevap şeklinde
Kafanıza takılan şeylerle de olursa
bunun konsepti böyleydi bu başka bir şey
yani oyun oynamak gibi değil tabii bu
çok farklı bir şey bakıyorum Evet sürem
doldu Peki ben çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]